je cite dans ses soutes et 10
d'expérience m'a demandé de partager un
morceau de mousse qui s'est passé c'est
ainsi que des raisins une chance de vous
faisait deux jours difficiles par
l'expérience visuelle 6e
il n'y a pas eu la même vigilance et
propofol on ne pensait pas forcément
entrepreneurs auront nous vous expliquez
que l'information nous était destiné à
laquelle ont été dessinés des formations
principalement deux cas le médecin
architecte autres à aucun moment évoqué
la possibilité de devenir entrepreneur
crée des emplois créés une société et
donc de quelque part pousser l'économie
et faire bouger les choses à son niveau
on valoir
donc je crois vraiment l'expérience
client le dr comme la plus importante
mais vingt deux en cavale ouvert les 5e
a ouvert des portes
et toi lmgt1 expérience certaine que
j'ai lancé un cancer qui est oui ça fait
donc ses vingt ans de long c'est droit
dans cette université que quand vous les
dirigent l'objet est l'objet même de
cette conférence tck des jeunes ont fait
face dans sa carrière dans son quotidien
cette nombre de chalets qui sont d'abord
que le commencement concis d'accord j'ai
envie de danser et partager un peu
la non turcs ont connu des 10es descente
et entrepreneurs entraînements on peut
commencer
on sort de l'université dans le cache
certaines universités ont rougi encore
parce que le premier et les d'études
voulais crier sa start up ne partent pas
recommencer on n'a pas cette éducation
on n'est pas sensibilisés aux différents
et n'importe quand on s'est plutôt le
système éducatif dont il est issu booth
a su des études avant les meilleurs des
poussières et c'est devant le meilleur
vin possible pour avoir le meilleur
accueil possible et ensuite aller vers
un stage à aucun moment on nous dit mais
d'une très bon pendant qu un très bel
orateur qu'une très bonne présentation
où tu es très créatif pourquoi ne pas
pousser ces aspects là on évoquera sa
densité de l'éducation actuelle
et ça c'est quelque chose ce serait mon
coup de gueule de m donc je crois
vraiment pas l'expérience et
entrepreneurs le but le plus le plus
important c'est de construire c'est
l'écran bouvier le plus tôt possible
je crois vraiment que le butô en bombe
ont échoué ou ont cessé l expérience le
plus vite on sera arrivé assez décevant
50 plus importantes plus difficile dans
ce cas dans la vie professionnelle donc
se construit quelle face à différentes
expériences être exposés à différentes
expériences c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment bien là milieu et que tu sais
pas moi
et c'est quelque chose à laquelle j'ai
dû faire face très très très tôt et
surtout les talents des ingénieurs des
qualifications assez poussée ils vont
venir contribuer au succès reste à venir
partager la cie l'image d'un couple en
99 d'hadji une année après leur accueil
en travaux c'est moi qu'ils étaient 23
sur la photo à l'hôpital subit c'est le
trio fondateur de gai fondateur le côté
mais c'est un problème auquel est
confronté également que l'on n'est pas
préparé mais à aucun moment je n'ai en
terminale scientifique me dit voilà
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour éviter
demain ce ou ces différents éléments qui
déterminent personne peut partager une
vision et voilà comment faire partager
cette personne le but commun et la
sensibiliser pour le faire participer à
aucun moment où les à ça aussi ça pollue
donc je crois vraiment que l'expérience
est très exposée que les mots ne pas en
être un stagiaire dans une société
mais vivre cette expérience vivre les
problèmes avec ses collaborateurs
partager l'expérience qui dans ce cas
you start up avait des nuits travaillées
journée
atroce mais c'est quelque chose qui est
très flatteur ce qu'on apprend l'étude
entre l'assuré on apprend de ces gens et
on construit quelque chose france 3 sont
plus considérés comme des symboles au
bordel c'est vraiment un noyau c'est
quelque chose qu'on va essayer des
créneaux dans le gt ans par exemple
annoncer des initiatives qui sont pas
très courante au maroc qui sont donnés
miss a thing ou des fosses qui s'est
beaucoup à l'étranger mais c'est donner
une motivation supplémentaire
supplémentaires en plus de salles et qui
ne va participer ce capitanat société
pour se sentir vraiment pour créer un
sentiment d'appartenance et c'est qu'on
fait dans des sociétés mount c'est tous
ces éléments là c'est des choses que les
entrepreneurs de rugby surtout du
national et après qui sont demandées
fait je me dis que le plus tôt
si le système éducatif et si la première
solution que dans les années à venir
on s'est retourné alors un autre
challenge que je ne connaissais pas mais
j'ai été confronté c'est ce qu'on a mais
de lénine starter le concept de
l'alliance start-ups et vous savez que
des sites internet
on est d'abord à s'intéresser
principalement du côté des ingénieurs
qui codent certain nombre de lieux pour
en créer des applications des joueurs
peuvent être exploitées par 1 5 million
de personnes l'instant l'investissement
c'est un concept qui vous pousse à
décéder en gros mon parti connaît une
start-up la base du serveur itunes à
partir de laquelle on est tannés des
hypothèses fléchage on essaye d'évaluer
les basques ont réussi à valider de ces
hypothèses ont construit une
organisation donc on essaie ensuite par
la suite de et architecturaux de
kickstarter en un set list un tel
contexte des idées son pays soutient
qu'avec les pense que nos utilisateurs
ont aimé les choses l'an dernier on a eu
un très gros succès le plus médiatique
assez importante
les mairies de passer de 0 à 100 est
membre en l'espace de six mois ces
derniers après ça ça stagne
pourquoi parce qu on était passé
j conserver des choses pour penser les
aimait pas dû on suppose des choix
pourrait jamais sur ses leçons d'unité
parce que on est tous dans un projet
pour les substrats réussite ça va
marcher mais toujours le lendemain donc
être au business de type cocktail à
l'elysée a été retirée elle s'avéra
dessus et se situe société capelli
encore une once d'émotion
aucun d'eux n'est pas exposé à c est ce
que vous verrez ce que c'est
c'est aberrant soit au départ trouve ça
c'était ma première expérience puisse
revenir un peu comprenez de challenge
1.3 j'avais 18 ans vous parvenu aux
débrouillards en route termine avec des
versions les variations c'est très
facile en fait des vagues à cet âge là
j'aurais fait les vagues et arriver à
quelque chose comme 300 en sentinelle et
j'étais allé à l'école et aux primaires
si tu veux je vais accepter ces mecs
c'est le jour et j'avais réussi arrivant
à 10 dirhams blessés en une semaine
j'avais réussi à amener quelque chose
comme ça sans nous y sommes à 7,8 en cd
est absolument une en outre je compte en
faire plus et faire des des ennemis de
milliers de neige s'en éloignant nom m'a
vite rappelé à l'ordre
je vais convoquer très vite dans le
rythme il m'expliquait qu'on pouvait pas
vendre au sein des bleus
ce stand j'allège je laissais tomber
sinon je laissais différents bruits mais
c'était un premier challenge assez de
gbc des mois pourrait continuer jusqu'au
bout mais c'est vous montrer qu'elle est
gérée déjà constamment muni bloqué ce
que vous avez à venir de cette
motivation c'est d'attention c'est tous
ces éléments qui font que vous allez
vous allez tout faire pour réussir
ecofin il ya toujours des mots
cela le jeu de la mjc on était considéré
par tous comme facebook n'était pas vu
comme on était réellement les gens
n'osent associés détiennent être associé
à facebook morgen on disait douzaine
serveurs d'ea fait déjà deux ans que
nous on est de 300 milles
donc si je mets dédié à c'est assez dire
à ces commentaires il aurait pu baisser
entre rapidement et on retrouve pas le
travail
je crois vraiment que toute entreprise
personne d'avoir une vision de ses
dirigeants
l'objectif est atteint chose qui paraît
très bon
il faut essayer donc les opportunités
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que
j'ai rencontré deux personnes
je tiens à dire une goutte entreprises
se sont installées soit le plus
important c'est vrai manque des
retraites la chance de faire des
recoupements et j'ai la chance d'avoir
un conseil d'administration de la
société qg qui est très
supporter dans l'oise india pti on se
rencontre et c'est des gens qui me sont
passées par la cedeao de reconnaître ses
défenses des investisseurs qui ont vécu
tout cinq jours vous allez dire ça n'a
pas beaucoup de
mersen conception stage en situation et
on a la chance de rejoindre un système
éducatif encore humide où des dizaines
de milliers de vols de comprendre ses
missions l'asie pourquoi ne pas les
années c'est quelque chose qui en vend
il faudra quelques années pour bander on
me met cigoland ça c'est juste pour nous
il ya beaucoup trop de différentes
expériences et aussi les opportunités
qu'on peut trouver il faut les chercher
avec l'algérie donnait la chance d'être
approché par le cerib centre en
organisation et on a remporté un prix
pour le maîtriser après
d'après ces deux souches et des
nouvelles technologies s'est bien repris
glendyne a qui vont financer l'état qui
finance un projet qui peut voter daba
girls qui va avec
pour le pays et le pousser s'ils n'ont
pas encore décollé que d'autres nations
pour présenter la chose il faut toujours
mais le gouvernement aujourd'hui cet
écosystème créations d'entreprises est
en train de nous salir j'étais plus
jeune mais je suis sûr que les
prochaines éditions du moment
aussi je n'ai vraiment pas quelque chose
qui est qui font la politique
aujourd'hui repas confiance donc la
deuxième chance a plu j'ai eu l'idée de
lever de vnf ont créé pour ça c'est
différent ça descend
koné suivant si vous remarquez ce vin
blanc 1 seulement humain mais qui n'est
pas peu dire que ces réserves
officielles elle est aussi impressionné
mais si l'investisseur ou d'une année
sur l'autre
poussez le repreneur de pousser et de
pousser le numérique est bon se
retourner ou pas avec dix stars peuvent
aller s'entraîner à la sympathique à
l'espace encan probablement le nouveau
prix n'est jamais un truc tu me manques
initiatives dans les domaines
donc ça c'est différent messieurs ont
permis d'arriver ont permis à la société
de ne recruter des gens de développer
son activité
si ces gens là n'avaient pas eu dans ma
vision des droits
c'est 1-0 sont aussi très important qui
va falloir pour ses revenus c'est
l'expérience
s'il super l'expérience à saugues loge
on est conquérant l'expérience d'apple
semble que je sais des personnes je ne
suis pas un héros post avant tout lui
parce qu'elles travaillent leurs projets
pour la pratique 5 en priant de ne pas
rouvrir aujourd'hui 300 on a produit du
passé
ces élections sont importantes qui sont
ambitieux mais en deux mots mais sa
famille car c'est une expérience que une
fois j'ai eu la chance de vivre aux gens
tombent donc qu'elle est long et le
chiffre paravent à la ville et ça c'est
nouveau
elle est jeune il est écrivain il
enseigne aujourd'hui 300 me mêle samedis
en boeing
on a aujourd'hui de croissance de 6000 à
7000 membres pour qu'ils s'inscrivent
donc celle qui très soutenue on vient de
lancer une initiative réagir et tunisie
commence avec très présent il ya partir
du deuxième trimestre 2013 compris moi
d'avoir une présence plus hâtif débit du
veulent donc c'est une star d'hollywood
qui a trouvé ces mots lieu premier bien
encore une fois je crois vraiment qu'il
ya encore des choses qu'on peut tous
faire
nicolas pour pousser sa une expérience
mobile
c'est le message principal de l'otan
dont un entrepreneur c'est quoi ce
travail si côté pataud les messages tout
ce que je faisais et ça c'est tout les
bourses et toutes les nuits il y avait
un refondateur de l'un des fonds
d'investissement les plus actifs en la
silicon valley un essaim browns qui
disait qu'un problème c'est quand même
plutôt un entrepreneur dans l'âme mm
sont identiques ils se réveillent t2 09
je crois que c'est le cas surtout au
début
c'est pas facile parce que les exposés à
beaucoup de risques pour les creuser un
beau coup de chalets en challenge et ça
serait trop facile ça se passe de
facilité de réétudier sa marche pas je
laisse tomber à ce genre de facilités
possibles de ces séances est vrai
beaucoup trop facile vous allez vous
lire
position et les locations mais ces cours
de l'hiver constant tous les jours comme
ça passe de manquer vous êtes la notion
de contrat et je ne vous apprends sur le
banc fait pour courir à lausanne
jamieson à vous apprenez sur une offre
et des érables 6 10 ans donc s'il y
avait un système qui vous permet des
droits rassemblant tous ces éléments
progressivement dans votre situation
vous passez donc on a besoin de plus
entreprenants et jeudi la technique
qu'ils se forment pouces entreprennent
de rentrer à la réflexion ne bougent pas
relève dallas concernant ce qualificatif
c'est la suivante comprend aujourd'hui
fonctionnaire comme notamment dans
l'éducation qu'on a reçue on évoque la
possibilité de créer un messie on le
sait que le filet social
il faut trentes cette mesure aux comptes
il faut l'intégrer à notre situation
très vite entrer dans des situations on
aura des vents sur gazon mais qui seront
pas forcément d'un département société
possédera ça c'est beau ça c'est une
initiation de mots et ces travaux
craignaient en fait tout ce que j'espère
le plus tôt dans la ville de challenge
et faites preuve fait face à des chats
et vous vous tombez le plus vite
construisez moutier protéger les prélats
d'anciens jeux aussi un héros que nous
allons essayer de venir à vous relever
contraire
portrait non plus voilà ce mini mais
j'ai beaucoup tient effectivement
surtout terriblement et maison